jesus louisardo he gets the ball today
his 18th start 25th game this year but
for the 12th time and final time in 2021
he suits up for the marlins
hit sharply there's a base into left
field for bow
and a one out single gets things rolling
here in the first inning
and he chases one there 97 up and above
the zone a strike down for luzardo his
first two away
two and two
and another fastball another strikeout
luzardo with two in the first inning
strands a runner and they'll face hans
krauss 23-year-old from dana point
california philly's got him in the texas
rangers trade
where spencer howard went to texas
fly ball to right that's right at bryce
harper and
we joked about being off the barrel he
was certainly off the barrel in this
inning
strikeout for luzardo make it three
that's three in a row for him
right now he's over his last 22 after
the strikeout and that is four in a row
for luzardo
a called strike three five in a row for
lucardo
that's ball four and leigh diaz is
aboard
up high for ball four so the marlins
have two on both by way of the free pass
fly ball out to left
freddy says he has it mccutcheon then
calls him off and makes the grab
off the knuckles out to shallow center
and it's going to drop for a hit
and andrew's aboard
there's a bun attempt he comes up empty
another strikeout for luzardo his sixth
3-2 pitch to luzardo is down and in and
the pitcher takes a walk
maggie lines the base it into center
field that's the marlins first hit of
the ball game their fourth base runner
though hogan sprouse has three walks
love to see this offense get rolling
it's been a long couple of weeks here
offense has really struggled hard time
putting things together
jazz with a line shot into right a
three-run homer
could barely get out of the box
a lightning bolt to right field and the
marlins
have a three-nothing lead yeah you had
to feel like the marlins were going to
start to put better swings against
krause out there the second time through
good disciplined at bats first time
through and
jazz leaning on that back side wow what
a swing
[Music]
that's lined up to right harper's going
back leaps up makes the catch
and a called strike three low inside
corner luzardo with his seventh
strikeout
ball's butted up the third base line and
that'll be a base hit for bryce
so he is a board with a bunt single
swing and a miss a slider ramuto down on
strikes that's eight k's for luzardo one
ball one strike to galvez
lines it and then
for freddie
that ends the old for 22 for freddie
galvez
opposite way for the reyes and that'll
drop in for a hit it kicks off the hip
of de la cruz
and a swing and a miss so luzardo
gets his ninth strikeout a new career
high
and a big out number one all right so
that means that matt vearling will be
the batter
line drive out toward left field that's
in for a base hit galvez around third
heading for home a little hesitation as
the throw goes to second it's an rbi
single for vearling it's a 3-1 game and
that young man just keeps on hitting
also
and he's going to lead things off
against christopher sanchez
and again look at that plate discipline
ground well left side galvez can't get
there base hit for miggy
[Applause]
out towards second tireas gonna have to
hurry there's one and two
a four six three double play sanchez is
able to get out of this fifth inning
and he's gonna face bryce harper who
leads off here in the sixth inning
but luzardo has struck out this mvp
candidate twice tonight and he's got
k's
and on that note it looks like the 2021
season ends for jesus luzardo you hoped
that he would end the year on a high
note and it cannot get any higher than
that
nothing in one from blyer
ground ball it's a heck of a play by
alvarez he takes a hit away from nap
oh the defense for the marlins tonight
has been stellar
miller with the drag button in field
single
it's sharply out to short on one hop
freddie the second for one back to first
in time and another double play
fly ball to center first of all hitting
brad miller a pinch hitter
back toward the track but short of the
track miller
there's a called strike three bottom of
the zone that power sinker from bender
two away
tapper back toward the mound
bender knocks it down whoa he fired it
right on past
diaz
well business about to pick up right
here 3-1 marlins lead with one of the
front-runners for the mvp at the dish a
2-2 from bender
is a cold strike three inside corner
froze harper and protects a 3-1 marlins
lead
throughout the rojas is down in a four
pitch walk for doei to his first big
league
hit her face
3-1 pitch is hit into left field a base
hit for de la cruz
0-2 pitch coming
swinging to miss he got his first major
league strikeout to wrap up this eighth
inning
no runs
one hit and it is up to dylan floro to
try to finish this one off his 67th game
this season in a save situation he has
13 of 19 in save ops so far
fluoro's 0-2 pitch a swing and a miss a
fastball to get mccutcheon first out in
the night
1-2 got him
back-to-back strikeouts for fluoro and
there are two outs and the one-two
line drive out toward right that's in
for a base hit phillies aren't done
blooping a blast baby freddie with his
second hit of the night
ground ball left side
jazz on the backhand makes the throw
over to first
it's a marlins win